[Music]
so
you're gonna love this
what if i told you
what if i told you
that bobby lee could have been in a
jamie foxx movie
but
what's her face
didn't
talked him out of it because it was a
racist asian stereotype
oh my god yeah and by the way taper as
you clip this can you bleep out the
and this
and then that
and that
thank you stop saying okay also that one
that one too okay or you could just
start the clip here it's like when i
turn down the asian accent well
you're making he's gonna kill you by the
way not me that's really funny
i'm sorry he's gonna kill you not me all
right here we go sorry i won't do it
again
it's like when i turned down the asian
accent thing well my whole family
pressured you to not take it
jamie foxx gig we're talking about a
jamie foxx movie even if you get to be
in a bad jamie foxx movie it's still
jamie's still you're gonna get the
residuals is what you look for movies
gonna get picked up by tnt or whatever
and you're still like 20 years down the
road be getting a residual check for it
see you were casting yourself as the
hero
i'm sorry it was chloe i don't know
about the phone call my sister and renzo
and i were like bobby you got it a year
ago
he turned down
a jamie yeah but at least at least he
did it for a woman he loves and they're
still together and they're not oh
[Music]
is that really i didn't know i didn't
see the second part of the video is that
really her sister i guess
well i don't really care so much about
this but i have some i have a little bit
more about the jamie foxx thing
uh
here you go a little more well they
talked about it a little bit more when
they went on our favorite podcast who by
the way loves us trash tuesdays shout
out to our girl esther what up esther
big ups
she would go that's silence with
fangs
and now this will be the flip side of
the bit that i was talking about last
week where now we get to see the other
side of brian callan melting down in the
room next and punching through the wall
yes you're right and then they connect
them
like i gotta watch both shows now yeah
well just cut this out but i turned down
a jamie foxx movie is what he's saying
there by the way because when it aired
live it wasn't bleeped and you could
read his lips very easily well really
why i think this is worth talking about
wait why did you turn a movie down
because it was um well i yelled a whole
lot but she
you made him a loser
she did too but um but look at this he's
trying to have some pride let's i think
his pride is stupid but let's say his
pride is i turned down a jamie foxx
movie
even they're broke even if they're
broken up now
yeah this is after they broke up she
won't
even let him have it no i made you do it
and by the way which i don't know if you
understand this
that makes you look worse
i wonder what movie it was
it says to me it was like it was there
was like an asian oh i didn't even read
that i'm so you know what i didn't even
read the title okay cool accent
right and it was a cool movie it's a
it's a vampire movie i could say that
yeah right probably a blockbuster kind
of maybe a blockbuster kind of a movie i
refuse oh yeah dayshift is [ __ ] him
trying to be blade i've seen the trailer
for that so it's going to be bad but
still let's look for the asian guy in
the credits so we see who he would have
played
uh
i don't
see any asian guys they might have just
cut the part they might have just cut it
it might have been in a scene that they
were gonna cut anyway huh
dude
could you imagine if [ __ ] bobby lee
turned down a role in a jaime fox film
that was written for him
i'm just looking at it
yeah i i i'm looking at this [ __ ]
um i mean people are watching it is is
it like a direct to netflix movie or
something is it yes
it's a direct
okay it's jamie foxx dave franco and
snoop dogg were the people in the movie
um it had a budget of 100 million
dollars
jesus there you go
news i honestly bobby 2021
you
if they told you marsh you're going to
be in a jamie foxx movie but you have to
play a stereotypical irish guy would you
do it i would be like top of the morning
to you exactly i'd be showing up
punching women in the eye drinking i
don't care just basically
not a cop an irish oh okay
i have made such you have blazed a path
for a lot of asian american
is this the hot air you've been blowing
up this little guy's butt there's
there's been no real prominent asian
comedians
before bobby lee okay all right
people in the industry the fact that you
would regress and do a film with an
accent would break my heart
but you're not going you don't suck his
dick anymore yes not sucking my dick
breaks my heart yeah so you don't get to
[ __ ] sit there and say [ __ ] like that
it would break my heart gives a [ __ ]
about your heart man you are still
trying to control him even after you
broke what is wrong with you she's a
psychotic person look and again she
slept with her brothers stepping real
and she used to jerk off dogs for fun
and those listen youtube when you review
this is you have to review this when i
try to monetize it she said that not me
hey we're not on youtube no i know but
the clip will be um okay okay
an accent would break my heart i won't
do it
anyway
yep
it's like when i turned down the asian
accent thing well my whole family
pressured you to not take it
[Music]
see you
if
frozen asian were to come to us tomorrow
and go hey guys
i turned down a role in a jamie foxx
movie because they were going to make me
talk in an asian accent i'd never talk
to him again
i'd fly to toronto and strangle him yeah
all right i'll just because he lives
i'll just pay pessy to do it you were
casting yourself as the hero
i'm sorry it was cloudy with that funny
no but the phone call my sister and
renzo and i were like bobby you got it a
year ago i get offered a huge action
movie but i have an asian accent but if
the character what's wrong with an asian
doing an asian accent for a character
that's supposed to be asian right what
if the role calls for the asian person
to have an accent do you have to
specifically find an asian person so i'm
sorry are you saying asian people who
actually talk that way are bad like this
they do this to themselves and then it's
all good that's that's cassandra isn't
it
is that is that is that that's that's
that's what's her face the mortal kombat
character no cassandra from wingsworld i
think
it is right it oh my god it is
sorry let me interrupt you but i just
saw that i'm like is that who that is
but i like this whole like oh yeah
you're gonna rest you're setting asians
back it's like all right then we'll just
have a white person do yellow face and
now you're out of job yeah what do you
want you never win
person and well thought up i should have
done that jamie foxx movie hey hold on
oh
boy oh wait did you see he just oh watch
out watch how he says that again watch
how he says it
there is a whole person and well thought
up i should have done that jamie foxx
movie no they only wanted you for the
accent
they said accent only please no i should
have done that no because it's coming
out now and i i should have done it oh
is it the vampire yeah yeah oh that
looks good it looks good right i should
have [ __ ] done it
i hate her i i i
despise this can i can i and can i say
at least i'm glad that bobby's finally
saying it
you know
i'm glad that he was fine like no i
should have done look how upset she is
that is the fakest smile you'll ever see
oh my god look at cassandra there at the
bottom what's going on there
i mean she's an old asian and i don't
want to by the way you can't pipe in
about the asian accent because i saw
wayne's world 2 and your dad was
literally dubbed over by a [ __ ]
american guy remember that
an accent
yeah i mean i talked to the director and
i just basically because i just i i
don't know if this guy needs to have an
accent he's in america he's there's
people in america with asian accents
yeah i don't understand the problem here
maybe i'm missing something
like he does and and that was where the
impasse like if somebody were to go well
you don't get an n-word passed you're
still asian i like but i like how he's
like yeah i just talked to the director
and i told him i felt like and it's like
you're a very
very minuscule insignificant part of
this you're a mad tv guy man you should
be happy
and that was where the impasse was and
you know when you you know who they
ended up hiring shane gillis to do the
same role
i mean gilly showing up
get it
i was like
then i'll pass you know what i mean and
it's like by the way if you've seen some
of shane gillis's sketch stuff it's all
really it's [ __ ] hilarious it's have
you seen the uh the bob isis of isis
toyota yes yes yes that one's that's the
older ones
i could have made that part fun mm-hmm
you know i could have made that part and
i mean because there are people in
america that have filipino accents yeah
thank you
now i really would she's like just take
the gig bro
i'm an aging asian woman i'll take the
[ __ ] gig anything they're giving me
now if it's a hallmark movie and i'm
supposed to go oh merry christmas ah so
so sorry to please yeah i'll be there
i'll be like what's his face the
breakfast of tiffany's i'll put butt
teeth in bro
no because if they go royce we need you
to we need you to play a cuban guy in a
movie and like okay but we need you to
really like cuban it up i'd be like bro
literally dude like bro on god bro i'm
[ __ ] the most cute i will show up
with an open y event and a wife beater
and five [ __ ] weight 40 grand for
four days work yeah all i have to do is
make my people look bad so basically do
an impression of my grandfather no
problem i got you i could do that right
now what do you want
i mean but it's on some [ __ ] [ __ ] they
talking about this [ __ ] oh bobby lee
setting it we really want to set us back
all right [ __ ] what is bobby lee
propelled forward how is he put [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so i [ __ ] up i should have been
getting dunked on by everybody in the
room knows you were wrong for listening
to her i'm so glad he's calling her out
sunday
go through your career
bobby lee when he's down
yeah and i should have [ __ ] done that
you know i mean vampire movie we all do
the best we can yeah you know that was
your family
trying to because now she said it wasn't
just her was her family that was her
family trying to entire family trying to
use bobby lee as their as their vocal
output for the asian community in turn
making them lose a jamie [ __ ] fox
movie look is the movie probably gonna
suck yeah probably but it's a paycheck
but it's a nice it's a nice jamie fox
movie that's a nice paycheck and if it's
on netflix you know what that means as
long as that movie's streaming you're
going to be making the residuals on that
money it's not going to be a lot but
it's money
and also put your name in the [ __ ]
ears of people at netflix to be in other
netflixs and if you're funny maybe they
go hey this bobby lee kid was in our
netflix movie you're right why don't we
ask him to do our next comedy special
here
and also wasn't your least ruined this
guy wasn't your entire existence on mad
tv getting paid much less money to just
reinforce asian stereotypes
i mean aren't you aren't you uh oh hot
dog guy
but you know what's funny about that
is not i mean she she completely she
completely ruined it and we're getting
mad at her but you know what it's still
his fault
he's the one that listened right
he's the one that listened